- [Interviewer] Okay, so I'm
sorry, what's your name again?
- My name is Pastor Troy.
- [Interviewer] Pastor Troy.
- Yes, sir. T leader great.
- [Interviewer] I'm sorry?
- T leader great. Also
known as Pastor Troy.
- [Interviewer] Excellent.
Tell me, tell me where you grew up.
- I grew up in Oakland, California.
- [Interviewer] Tell me about childhood.
You had both your parents as a kid?
- Well, my childhood ummh, single parent,
my mother raised me
and my father was in the military
and came back
and unfortunately he was
messed up from the Vietnam war.
So he's had a bad drug habit.
So my mother raised me full time
get everything she could do.
She was a great parent.
- [Interviewer] How was your childhood?
- My childhood For the
most part, like I say,
it was a typical childhood
for a Black African American
male, single parent.
You know, I didn't have
everything that I wanted
but I had everything that I needed.
For the most part, I can't complain.
I can say that I never went with,
I never went without.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. Other
than your dad's drug addiction,
seems like a pretty, problem free.
- Well, it was a problem
at first growing up because
you know, every young male
needs their father in their life
and wants to know where they are.
But as I got older, I
kinda understood, you know
the psychological problem
that he was going through
from being so far away
from home in the war.
So as I got older, I kinda accepted it
and it didn't bother me after
probably the age 12 or 13.
But before that, yeah, it
was, it was pretty tough.
- [Interviewer] And
then you got introduced
to pimping game at what age?
- I got introduced to the game at first,
at the age of 19 years old.
- [Interviewer] And you
had role models around
that showed you.
- Yeah, for surely my
role models was Kenny Red.
He always, was the role model
that I looked up to growing up
and also hamp banks out of San
Francisco, California Filmo.
I looked up to those guys, you know,
they always were the person that I seen
that was having all the money
had all the beautiful women
and I kinda gravitated to them
because then was the role
models that I wanted to be like.
So I kinda sucked up the game
and listened to everything
they had to give.
- [Interviewer] So how did
you get your first girl?
- I got my first girl at
the age of 19 years old.
She was a girl that
was in the neighborhood
little pretty little bitchy you know
she was in not doing
nothing with her life.
She just liked to hang out, smoke, drink
and you know, just be around.
She didn't have any, nothing going on.
So, you know, me being a young grasshopper
that I was at that point in time in life
I was just fucking on her, you know?
And then eventually I seen that I had,
she had potential to get some money
because she was always willing to have sex
with multiple people at the same time.
So I introduced her to the game
and told her that she trusted
believed in me that I could show her,
how to get a whole bunch of money.
And from near, I just
jumped off the diving board.
- [Interviewer] How many
girls did you have eventually?
- At that point in time?
At that point in time,
that was my first girl.
But the most girls I ever had
at one time was four.
All stumped down straight laced
all one stable one house.
- [Interviewer] And how much
of the money do you keep?
- I keep everything.
You know, I don't go half with no bitch.
If I'm gonna give the half of the money
I'm gonna give her half of my pimping.
So guess what?
I don't do nothing half.
So everything is always profit, no splits
but I definitely make
sure they get everything
that they need, what they want.
- [Interviewer] What do they get?
- They get everything that
they need, that they want
in order to continue to get my money
such as you know, a vehicle.
They need a vehicle,
So they can go handle their business.
They, all the flyest
wardrobe that they, you know
gotta stay fly to catch a trick eye.
Some money, you know,
the bank account.
They get whatever they need,
some to take care of
their family, you know.
Whatever they need,
if I feel like it's
something that is mandatory,
it's not problem with getting it.
That's why they in the game for.
- [Interviewer] Have
you been in prison time?
- Definitely.
- [Interviewer] What
was the prison time for?
- Pimping and pandering?
Living off the earnings
and persuading a witness.
- [Interviewer] You guys are what races?
Black, White, Hispanic?
- At that point in time,
the girls I was dealing with
two was Black and one was Mexican.
- [Interviewer] Hmm, and
you have sex with the girls?
- For surely I have sex with the girls.
Who else I'm gonna have sex with?
I'm not gonna go check
my dick out with a bitch
or a square whore that
ain't doing nothing for me.
If I'm having sex with any girl
it's gonna be the girl
that's in my stable.
That's in my life.
That's making sure daddy
got everything they need.
- [Interviewer] What do you,
how do you handle a girl
when she gets out of line?
- I mean you know, I'm not
really with the on hands
gorilla Pimpin type.
You know, that the world look at pimps do.
I can use my mouthpiece
and I could break her down
and make her feel so small.
But at the same time,
I can make her understand the problems
that we're having because
of what she's doing.
You know?
So at the most I ain't gonna say
I've never have put my hands on a bitch.
You know what I'm talking about.
But for the most part, I
just chop them real bad.
Let them know what they're doing
and make them stand in the corner
and put their nose up against the wall.
- [Interviewer] What's
more important to you.
Money or love?
- Money.
- [Interviewer] You've ever been in love?
- I definitely been in love before.
When I was a young grasshopper
you know, high school, adolescent days.
I definitely was in love.
And I can't say I'm not in love right now
with a bitch that goes outside every day,
who put her freedom on the line, you know,
who put our life on the line
that do whatever it take to make me happy.
How can I not love
somebody that's doing that?
That's genuine love.
- [Interviewer] The laws have
changed since the old days
the penalties are much
straighten, you know
much harder now.
(indistinctive)
- [Interviewer] You afraid
of any imprison again?
- Well, you know, and that's
why I had to take a step back
and you know, do something
else with my life.
Because right now I so don't
wanna go back to prison
over dealing with a female, you know
back then it was number
to slap on the wrist.
Now they talk about human trafficking.
You know, you looking to have a life,
over dealing with a prostitute.
That's been doing this longer
than you've been doing it.
And better yet.
She has a resume of whoring
in 50 States, 50 cases
but they want to blame the man.
Like they brainwashing
the bitch to do something.
So once they start
getting serious like that
and I did that for 16 months,
I had to retreat man kicked bracket
do something else for me.
That's not worth it no more.
- [Interviewer] So,
you're no longer active?
- Right now I'm no longer active.
You know, luckily I was able to stack up
enough money to do what I needed to do
in order to take that money
and do something positive.
That was the reason why I'm in the game
to take illegal chances, to get some money
so that I could do some
legal with the money.
So, you know, I was able to money
launder and do something
a lot smarter now.
- [Interviewer] Would you
specifically look for girls
that could steal from guys?
- [Troy] I mean, no,
it's more than one way.
Very best to get some money. You know.
Stealing is always a good thing.
You know, the Rolex,
the ATM card, you know.
However whatever, but you know.
Sometimes you can't steal none
or sometimes its not a predicament.
So if they can't steal it
they need more than one way to get it.
- [Interviewer] What's the
craziest thing you've seen?
- [Troy] As far as what?
- [Interviewer] Like one of the,
what the girls have had
to do or what they've done
for money or anything about
the game that you've seen.
- [Troy] Man, I didn't see some cold shit,
but I'm have to say
I was in LA on Figueroa man.
And then a bitch got kidnapped.
She got gang raped by five gang bangers
and they fucked her in
the ass with a high heel.
That's the craziest thing
that I think I've really
really experienced
in the game, man.
- [Interviewer] And you have kids?
- [Troy] Definitely. I have two.
- [Interviewer] You raising them?
- [Troy] No, I'm co-parenting
with the parents.
- [Interviewer] You have boys or girls?
- [Troy] I have one boy, one girl.
- [Interviewer] What would
you, how would you feel
if your son or daughter kinda
followed in your footsteps
and like one of the girls became,
your daughter became a prostitute
or your son became a pimp?
- [Troy] I mean, one
thing for sure, you know,
I wouldn't want my kids
doing nothing illegal
to be in the streets.
That's why I went so hard
so that I can give them the opportunity
that they didn't have to
take no penitentiary chances
but they was going to be in the game.
You know, I would just want them to know
really really know what they doing.
And what's the purpose of doing it.
No, I can't say that I would be mad
and I can't say that I'd be happy.
It'll just be something
that I have to accept.
You know, it's a tough pill to swallow
but hopefully they can get
in and get out, you know
and go on about eight minutes
and do something bigger or better.
- [Interviewer] What's
the most important lesson
you've learned doing this?
- Man. The most important
lesson I learned was,
the streets don't love you.
These bitches is not faithful.
And they only own you for a moment.
That is not your bitch.
I'm talking about,
that's just your bitch for the moment
and that you need to hurry up
and get some money and get
up out the streets from here.
Because at the end of the day,
you're going to end up
chasing a little dream
and end up somewhere you don't want to be.
So stay focused get what you gonna get
and get up out of it.
- [Interviewer] All right,
man. Well, thank you so much
for sharing your story
- Yes Sir
and good luck with
wherever you go from here.
- I appreciate you, man.
- [Interviewer] Thanks man.
- Thank you.
I'm from California.